♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
STEPHEN PANDOS:
This is Jennifer's note.
JENNIFER PANDOS: I can't erase
the things I've done.
There is no place left to run.
Life is hard, but it goes on.
Live my days
as if they were my last.
(SCHOOL BELL RINGS)
STEPHEN: Jennifer Pandos
was reported missing in 1987.
SPEAKER: Never been seen
or heard from since.
STEPHEN: I'm Jennifer's brother.
I reached out to an attorney
about whether
I could sue my parents
for the death of my sister.
For the first 22 years
of her disappearance,
everything I'd been told,
you know, was a lie.
I thought, at first,
she had run away
and that she didn't tell me.
And it's like,
who is this person?
STEPHEN: I think my mother
knows what happened.
You waited two days
to call the police?
My father scared her
to keep this a secret.
-So, you really think I did it?
-STEPHEN: (OVER PHONE) Yes.
SPEAKER 2:
They both failed polygraphs.
I wanna know the truth.
I cannot tell you something
I don't know.
STEPHEN: The story around
Jennifer's disappearance,
it doesn't make sense.
It feels like
you've convicted me
of something
that I haven't done.
SPEAKER 3: This must be
very emotional for you.
My heart is racing
a mile a minute.
Everybody has that case
that impacted them
more than any other.
STEPHEN: The shame of thinking
my parents were involved.
SPEAKER: It's made him
question everything.
SPEAKER 4: Why are you
so consumed about this?
Because it's only right,
and she deserves better.
-You think it's crazy...
-(KNOCKING)
...and then, all of a sudden,
it's even more crazy.
I'll never give up on Jennifer.
I just have to keep on going.